all right I think we are going live so
god I am at the New York City and
Caitlyn is in Wyoming normally I only do
the podcast live in person but Caitlyn
has been kind enough to on a Sunday jump
on this livestream and we're gonna try
to figure this out because we may be
doing more remote live cast for for a
while now yeah I'm afraid that's true a
lot of people are gonna have to have a
lot of patience about logistics in the
next few weeks of remote working and
remote conversations but thank God for
the engineers who can figure this out
salute you Allison
so guys just bear with us here a second
as we take another 30 seconds or so
we're gonna get some some more folks in
on on the livestream and then we're also
going to tweet out the the youtube link
so that folks can can get in here too
and watch let's see so we actually out
the the youtube link which is good news
Caitlyn I'm gonna send you to take now
let's yeah let's go ahead and we'll
tweet out this will tweet out the
YouTube like and then we'll get started
here at the conversation yep Joe just
sent it to you so I think we should we
should be good let's tweet this link out
then we'll go ahead and get this good
bought the cup what they start leaked
leaked that does Caitlyn justice for all
of the amazing work she's about to
livestream
conversation with Caitlyn
[Music]
okay so I think that that tweet should
have just gone out and we'll see how how
that goes
all right Caitlin let's let's jump right
in for those that don't know you the
small few maybe just give us kind of a
quick two minutes on your background and
and what you've done previously in terms
of career-wise before getting into a
Bitcoin sure I've grew up in Wyoming
trained lawyer spent 22 years on Wall
Street working in the traditional
financial services industry managing
director at a couple of different places
and in my career my Wall Street career
at Morgan Stanley where I was running
the pension solutions business and got
into Bitcoin in 2012 which was before I
left Morgan Stanley in 2016 and I
spotted it as something that would
actually help solve some of the issues
that I've identified in the traditional
financial services industry
left in 2016 to work on blockchain
technology full-time did a detour
through an enterprise blockchain
technology company before coming back to
the decent decentralized protocols and
worked as a volunteer for the last two
years unpaid helping in my native state
of Wyoming where I just returned to
after 29 years to create a legal and
regulatory regime to welcome the digital
and I just announced last month I'm
gonna start a new type of special here
in Wyoming to help provide 100% reserved
no rehypothecation full strong balance
sheets financial services to the digital
asset industry I love it so before we
get into how we're doing now let's start
from the beginning you'd mention that
you had identified a bunch of issues
that were kind of persisting in the
legacy world maybe walk us through what
those issues were and how they kind of
led into what we've seen over the last
two weeks or so yeah I in 2008 during
the financial crisis I got very curious
because the mainstream explanation for
things stopped making sense and frankly
I think a lot of more people are
figuring out in the last couple of weeks
that that same thing is true and
arriving at the same conclusion probably
that's why a lot of people are here they
want to hear a different view and
understand that maybe the mainstream
explanation doesn't quite make sense
anymore and I think that's right I had
that experience in 2008 a lot of people
who taught me had that experience in
1999 or even before so what it was in
2008 that didn't make sense is they is
Treasury Secretary Tim Geithner at the
time said interest rates were too low he
acknowledged on Charlie Rose's show I
think that the that that that was what
caused the mortgage crisis and then a
couple days later I heard him give an
interview where he was job owning the
Fed to interest rates lower interest
rates even still and obviously that was
a logical disconnect that I just got
very curious
and started digging and intuitively knew
something was wrong and it really I did
I dug deep I I actually and and and what
brought at the same time I read a lot of
alternative schools of economic thought
read a lot of history and started
putting puzzle pieces together that what
I have learned in school and what I paid
a fortune for my education for wasn't
really the way the world worked and the
way the world worked is actually
something that falls squarely in the
school of common sense but not squarely
in the school of what what most
mainstream economists think about the
world and and so again I think that's
probably why a lot of folks are here
because there's an understanding that
something's wrong and they're not
getting the real story yeah I think it's
a great way to put it in so this past
week we've seen what I'll call very high
levels of volatility across a number of
different markets we've seen what I've
categorized as kind of this liquidity
crisis where everyone's running to the
door and selling as much of these liquid
assets as they can to try to get dollars
and then we saw obviously over the last
couple of weeks the emergency interest
rate cut and then this monetary stimulus
announcement of the this past week may
be kind of helped us make sense of like
what is happening and then we can tie it
through that like how we've gotten here
but just in your sense like what is
actually happening right now well we're
having some pretty severe dislocations
in financial markets the so-called
risk-free asset which is US Treasury has
had a pretty crazy week there were
bid-offer spreads of as wide as a
hundred basis points in the 30 or
Treasury this past week which is really
scary but because that's how the US
government funds itself and that's how
the big banks also increasingly fund
themselves for the less when I say
increasingly for the last 15 years
that's how the big banks have funded
themselves is through what's called the
repo market and repo is essentially
you're just posting collateral typically
a US Treasury in return for cash
financing and so when the US Treasury
market starts to
some pretty severe dislocations you know
that something's really wrong and in
fact actually the feds bazooka that was
introduced the one and a half trillion
dollar stimulus came right before a
troubled 30-year Treasury auction I've
said for years for those of you who've
been following me that that's the thing
that I'm most worried about is a failed
Treasury auction and you know if we have
challenges with that that starts to that
basically that's how the US government
funds its deficits by issuing Treasury
bonds you know that that is that is how
if god forbid there are problems with
the FDIC and the FDIC insurance fund
which I would invite you to go and look
at how big that is relative to the size
of the banking sector hint-hint it's
very small and if the FDIC needs more
money they have to go to the US Treasury
which would have to issue Treasury bonds
we start having problems with Treasury
bond issuance it's a challenge now that
said they did get the auction off and
and and the Fed it clearly helped but
it's the kind of thing that you know the
stock market gets the headlines but the
real action is in the fixed income
market and I've been watching indicators
in the fixed income market which have
been flashing really loud red sirens if
you knew where to look since last fall
and even frankly for the last couple
years it's been obvious that we're in
the fourth such financial system
disruption since 2008 and this is this
is definitely the worst one since 2008
if not worse than 2008 we don't know yet
okay so let's kind of take this one
piece at a time so I think there's a lot
of people who have no clue about the
Treasury markets about how the auctions
work and why that's so important maybe
explain how do these auctions work and
then also why that they're so crucial
each other what kind of funding for the
government etc if you can explain both
how the auctions work and then why
that's the thing to pay attention to I
think a lot of people kind of get it a
little bit better
yeah the auctions are really the nerve
center of capital markets and like I
said the Treasury bond US Treasury is
considered so-called risk-free asset I
put that deliberately and
air quotes but but there are a number of
so-called primary dealers that are
required to step up and bid on on those
auctions and then they turn around and
resell the Treasuries but effectively
they're guaranteeing that the Treasury
Treasuries get sold but to the extent
that the banks have challenges with with
their own funding keep in mind that's
sort of a loop right because the banks
actually need those Treasuries at the
same time for them to get funding in the
repo market so I probably won't go into
more details than that but let's step
back and understand about the auction
specifically but but the big picture is
what does it mean the US Treasury is
essentially the reserve asset of the
securities industry just like the so
called monetary base is the reserve
asset of the traditional banking
industry and what happens is that a huge
amount of debt gets piled on on top of
those so-called reserve assets again
Treasuries in the securities industry
and monetary base in the banking sector
most of you if you studied economics in
school understand how fractional reserve
banking works that you take a dollar of
so called monetary base and then
typically the bank's issue out ten
dollars worth of loans through
fractional reserve multipliers that you
turn one dollar of monetary base into
ten dollars of credit that's the way the
traditional banking system works but
that's not where most of the credit has
been issued in the economy or in the
financial system in the last couple of
decades most of it has been issued in
the so called shadow banking system
which is really the securities markets
where Treasury bonds which are I owe use
of the US government just like or
analogous to the monetary base being an
IOU or the Federal Reserve again both of
these I owe use they're a really
important point we're gonna pile even
more IOUs on top of that and there's
actually a lot more leverage than ten to
one in the in the securities industry
and so when you think about the fact
that a lot more leverage got piled on
those Treasuries that the next question
is alright what happens if we get into a
deleveraging environment you usually see
a run to to safety and and again the
risk-free risk-free in quote air quotes
that is is the Treasury bond and we see
the rush to safety we certainly saw that
Treasury yields collapsed which meant
that the price went up because yield and
a price move in opposite directions
you saw them hit record lows across the
entire interest rate curve US Treasury
interest rate curve this past week and
so there was a rush to rush to quality
but then you start to get the the
reality that in fact actually liquidity
has kind of disappeared from these
markets and it took a Fed bazooka to get
a 30-year Treasury auction done the
auction was done at a relatively good
yield it was only a couple basis points
wide but but the what's called the bid
to cover the it the internals of that
auction we're really challenging so it
just is it it's indicative that we're in
a pretty severe dislocation and the
financial markets even more so in fixed
income than in equities got it and so
when you say that that auction was in
trouble and the Fed steps in with you
know the 1.5 trillion dollar
announcement explain kind of the
mechanisms of they say hey we're going
to inject this liquidity but what
exactly is happening there from a
mechanism standpoint so that people
understand kind of how they quote say
yeah so so the the injection of
liquidity is literally injecting
reserves into the banking system
injecting cash into the banking system
the Fed's balance sheet increases some
people call that printing money that's a
that's an outdated term but it's still a
term that describes what's going on
you're literally creating the feds
writing a cheque on itself they're
creating assets out of thin air
and expanding their balance sheet and in
the last crisis in 2008 the Fed's
balance sheet was about 800 million and
then it swelled up to well over 4
trillion and then the Fed started to
reduce its balance sheets it threw
through as it was raising interest rates
and and letting some of the assets that
it had purchased run off but now that's
reverse course and now the feds
increasing its balance sheet again and
and so from the Fed perspective we're
north of four trillion I think around
4.2 4.3 trillion of
of fed balance-sheet right now again up
from 800 million in the last financial
crisis one of the analysts who I must
take my hat off to Doug Nolan who really
got this whole thing right and has been
chronicling what was coming in the in
the credit markets it he predicted that
the Fed's balance sheet would swell to
10 trillion in this next crisis which I
think is here he predicted that by the
way he's been predicting that all along
so that's not a new prediction and and
at the time and she thought last fall
when he published it most recently it
struck me as way too low and in fact
actually I think it's going to turn out
to be way too low so everyone from my
perspective and again I should step back
and say none of this is advice you're
getting what you're paying for here this
is just one person's perspective and you
can't rely on it but hopefully it'll
just help make you think that's the only
thing I want to want and what would like
for you all to take away from this is
just one person's perspective to help
make you think it's just it's a
different perspective than you're gonna
read in the mainstream press but anyway
coming back to that is the 10 trillion
dollar number that much you know I back
it back in last fall I think a lot of
people were shocked by that prediction
and at the time I said no way that's way
too low the Fed's balance sheet is
actually going to be a it end up being a
lot bigger than that now what's the
impact it means that the banking system
is very liquid from the traditional
banking system they've got all kinds of
cash the problem is that cash is in the
wrong place it doesn't help the
securities markets because the banking
industry in the securities industry are
really pretty separate there are a few
of the gigantic banks the money center
banks that are in both sides there are
traditional banks and their and their
Securities Dealers primary dealers that
that handle Treasury auctions for the US
Treasury and but but even there they
actually the balance sheets are
typically not even in the same legal
entity so there's some there's that the
cash is going into the traditional
banking industry but not into the
securities industry and and that's part
of the reason why you see these
dislocations that don't totally make
sense but in fact actually if you
understand the plumbing it
makes sense yeah and so help us
understand right when we talk about this
kind of expansion of the balance sheet
one of the things that I saw on Twitter
recently is I think Ben Bernanke on a 60
minutes episode somebody said to him you
know what exactly like where is this
money coming from are using taxpayer
money and he you know kind of
nonchalantly said no we just go in and
we just edit the account number so they
need to talk a little bit about that
expansion of balance sheets and the fact
that the number really is backed by
nothing and is kind of at will can be
expanded without any kind of logic bond
well you just laid out exactly the way
who works the Fed is literally writing a
check on itself it's the only
institution only bank it's illegal it's
legally a bank it's the only bank that's
allowed to do that to literally create
money out of thin air and then it's it's
monetary base like I said gets
multiplied by other banks who are
allowed to create a different type of
money out of thin air but all this is
coming out of thin air now if what's the
what's the real impact of it it's all
debt it's right it's all an IOU actually
in fact even the dollar is an IOU
everything's in IOU go look at the
dollar in your wallet if you have one it
says Federal Reserve Note pay to the
order of it is it is a debt instrument
the dollar itself is a debt instrument
so everything everything is an IOU piled
on top of an IOU piled on top of an IOU
that's a really important point I think
to some for some listeners that's going
to be news most of you probably
understand that the the banking system
is an IOU we don't legally own the
deposits in our bank account that's a
promise to pay from our banks so
effectively we've lent them the dollars
we've deposited in the bank
the the piece that very few people
understand in my experience though is
that the same is true in the securities
industry we think we own the shares in
our brokerage account in fact we don't
they are IOUs the same way that the
deposits in our bank account are io
u--'s we're actually taking an
obligation from our counterparty to
deliver us the asset and they have an
obligation from a different counterparty
to deliver them the asset and they have
enough
locations from a different counterparty
to deliver them the asset and there's a
huge daisy-chain of IOUs in the
securities and banking industries
respectively they both work the same way
and so but at the end of the day the
bottom remember I talked about the base
asset in each of the two types of
financial industries the banking
industry and the securities industry the
base asset in and of itself is an IOU to
your point yeah and so let's talk a
little bit about kind of how we've
gotten here right because this is not
something where nobody saw it coming
there's actually quite a few people
who've been publicly saying there's
issues there's issues and I don't want
to say that anybody was like you know
it's gonna happen in January or February
or March 2020 I think it was more of
just these problems can't persist
forever and I think one of the first
things is the coronavirus or covet 19
now there's a lot people are saying oh
this is all because of the virus I think
you and I are in the boy these foods
we're gonna happen anyways the virus is
likely the accelerant the thing that
causes an economic slowdown and exposes
these structural flaws maybe talk a
little bit about the relationship to the
virus and also what those structural
flaws yeah the virus is just the pin
that's pricking the bubble and the
bubble the the the the credit bubble is
by far the bigger issue the virus will
definitely be a problem for everybody
right you know everybody's holed up at
home or if you're not you should be to
try to reduce the spread Balan Tara Lee
you should be to try to protect the
elderly and and and the and the folks
that are more susceptible to it because
it is so contagious and we can come back
and talk about that I've actually worked
on pandemic bonds earlier in my career
so I was I was pretty sensitive to this
and and to your point that not a lot of
people predicted the timing something
like this you couldn't predict right a
virus coming out but I will say those of
us who were worried about who we're
looking for what would be the catalyst
of a problem in the financial industry
we were pretty focused on this pretty
early on and again I got a dig give Doug
Nolan credit and it was his credit
bubble bullets
on Saturday January 25th I started
tweeting out about it and said oh my
gosh this might be the the thing that
pricks the credit bubble and maybe
that's part of the lens I was looking
through because I was worried that there
you
as you spend their lives studying these
these sorts of things one of the things
they were worried about the number one
net calamities would of course be you
know a nuclear war or a supervolcano
going off but but you know the a
sustained power grid downtime is also
right up there in terms of severity of a
disaster but but the next one on that
list is a pandemic it always was and
this was always have been worried about
is a flu we because it's so contagious
and by the way I did post on my Twitter
account a couple of days ago there's a
prospectus from the World Bank's
pandemic bond which is the most recent
one the ones I worked on paid off a long
time ago and and and they didn't trigger
but this World Bank pandemic bomb did
trigger if you're interested in the
history you should go take a look at
that because that is that's based on
hard math it's actuarial science and and
a lot of study of exactly what happens
in the 1918 Spanish flu which is still
to this day the worst flu that has hit
in recorded times it was actually even
though it's called the Spanish flu Spain
got a bad rap because they were just the
first one to step up and admit that it
was happening it does the actuaries dou
X dou accept the the the alternative
story which is that it actually started
in the United States started it looks
like on pig farms in the Oklahoma
Colorado border in 1918 it went all
throughout the world
it was extremely contagious in fact it
looks like this corona virus we're
facing now is even more contagious than
that was but luckily the death rate from
from the corona virus is a lot lower
than
in the 25 to 45 year old age group this
way is not this one is
disproportionately hitting hitting
elderly so I went off top again and
completely forgot that Kristin you asked
me sorry about that but know that you
should read about that yeah I think one
of the key pieces to this whole thing is
when you talk about popping this credit
bubble what essentially happens here is
the virus starts to spread there is very
serious health concerns with that so
whether it is fear induced or actually
that the true health concerns what
eventually occurs is everyone has to
stay inside right and so you get a
complete drop off and travel we're
seeing across the United States
these reservation apps are reporting 50
percent or more in some cases drops in
restaurant visits the airline industry
is completely being decimated rosing
as if millions of dollars Cruise Line's
hotels Airbnb etc and that slow trickle
across the economy is not just on the
consumer side it also happens on the
corporate side and so in a world where
everyone has been levering up with debt
you know for years now all of a sudden
they get a slowdown in revenue and EBIT
uh in in true cash flow they can't pay
the interest on that debt and you get
this kind of trickle effect across the
economy these mini blow ups of that debt
and I think that's really what you're
talking about here in terms of as that
domino effect starts we don't know how
big it is and how long it will last and
that's kind of the big concern if I
understand where you're coming from is
that anga yeah you Fred you phrase it so
well yeah I've forgotten to come back
around to you know those of us who were
who were looking for the who realized we
were in an incredible debt bubble saw a
blow off top Lee I was tweeting out
yesterday looking at the updating of fed
numbers in my own spreadsheet we had a
ten percent increase in the total amount
of debt outstanding in the just the last
two years in the United States that's a
huge acceleration and increase in debt
we certainly didn't grow GDP 10 percent
over the last two years let's put it
that way so we were we just let him in a
drunken stupor and so we were those of
us who were looking at that kind of
those kind of statistics were sensitive
to what could pop the credit bubble and
then when the coronavirus came around
that that's you know there again Doug
Nolan was the first person that I saw
who called it back on
gerrae back then no none of us were how
how big of an issue this was going to be
but let me make this clear the
coronavirus is going to blow over flues
blow over the 1918 flu lat it had three
different waves but it it only lasted 15
months and it killed several hundred
million people in the world but it
burned itself out in 15 months this too
shall pass the bigger issue is exactly
what you talked about which is that
there are a lot of leveraged businesses
who were not set up to have a to
withstand a shock like this and it turns
out with the debt bubble that we've had
in the US economy that the US economy is
actually really vulnerable to this and
as I was tweeting out back in January in
with after reading Doug's post I'm
worried about China's economy as well
because China has accumulated debt it
only took them 15 years to accumulate
the same amount of debt that it took the
United States more than 50 years to
accumulate so there the acceleration of
debt in China has has also been
something that that you know a lot of us
have been watching as well and so that
you've got certainly the the Western
world the Americas and Europe having
been heavily leveraged going into this
coronavirus event but you also have to
have heavily leveraged as well so what's
interesting is that it really is global
with the exception of a couple
severa they might have wanted to if they
had access to the financial system but
ironically you know they're coming into
the coronavirus with stronger balance
sheets and as a result I think they'll
bounce back quicker because they just
don't have all these debt defaults that
are going to be triggered because we
were you know operating at the edge from
a leverage perspective in in these
leveraged economies including that of
the u.s. doe there's this weird dynamic
of like there's a bunch of people right
now they're like holy [ __ ] I can't
believe that we've gotten ourselves in
this position at the same time there's a
bunch of other people that are like
hello welcome to market cycles right
2008 occurs everyone gets kind of super
everyone talks about cash flow and
strong balance sheets and all this stuff
over time we get access to chief capital
people start to take on a little bit
more risk than a little bit more risk
and a little bit more debt and and it
kind of balloon
through that bear market and now you get
into the raging bull market the longest
in history and where you end up is
basically right back where you were
maybe it shifted a little bit in terms
of the industries it's affecting except
sure but it's still just classic market
cycle stuff so one of the things you've
talked a lot about is kind of the debt
that the banks have taken on and though
the lack of the strong balance sheets
and maybe even the need for them to go
raise equity capital kind of give us an
understanding of the banks specifically
how do they fit into this how should I
adamant about them go and raise equity
yeah I started really banging this drum
in June of last year that I could
because I could I was watching these
these the repo market signals clear that
there something was really wrong in in
the in the market that the big banks
rely upon in order to fund themselves
and you know we saw in 2008 the repo
market totally seized up and then the
banks needed
first molar situation now and and and
and the thing that shocked me was that
when the Fed did its stress tests for
the big banks it
said everybody passed and allowed them
to go start buying back stock well boy
does that in history look like it it was
a decision that did an age very well
shall we say and then things got a lot
worse in in in the fall and I wasn't
alone in editing but look you raise
capital if you're a bank when you can
and when it's abundant and you don't
wait until things the wheels start
coming off because then you're going to
dilute your shareholder so massively
when you do and but but actually
probably the skeptic in me says they've
been bailed out so many times why would
they dilute their own equity they should
you know they'll just wait for for for
either the Fed to bail them out
indirectly or in the case of 2008 the US
government directly bailed them out by
investing in them and a skeptic in me
says maybe that's what they were
thinking
I don't know needless to say the banks
are way to leverage that was a very
contrarian view I remember a lot of
people calling me nuts for saying that
but what but I was watching the income
markets and it was very clear that the
situation was really getting to be
unstable and you know and then then we
saw the Fed reverse it's it's it's it's
interest rate increases and now we've
seen them even starts to cut rates again
and it was just obvious to those who
were
being of the fixed-income indicators in
particular the liquidity in the repo
market it was just obvious that this
this was a problem and now that said if
the banks are over leveraged what does
that mean it means the economy is over
leveraged plain and simple
we'd like to blame the banks but the
banks are just the financial industry is
just a pass-through of debt to the real
economy when when I talked about the 10%
increase in debt in the last two years
between twenty and twenty seventeen and
twenty nineteen that was households
businesses and government and just to be
clear that I'm not being political here
boy
the government debt has ballooned a lot
since 2008 it's been both political
parties there doesn't seem to be anybody
who is concerned about this both both
politically but it's not just the
government sector it's been the
corporate sector in the household sector
as well so the financial sector is
literally just a mirror of what's going
on in the real economy that the
households businesses and government
sectors and all three of those have been
petals of the metal
on on borrowing really for the last 50
years this is just to be clear we I'm
talking a lot about 2008 but we've had
so many attempts by the free market to
assert itself
was 1968 we did have one year during the
financial crisis during which we saved
more than we borrowed but every other
year since then we've borrowed more than
we saved what does that mean it means
that we're consuming more than we
produced it's pretty simple and so if
you go back in history why did the u.s.
have why why did we become the strongest
economy in the world especially coming
off World War two and the answer is we
had the strongest balance sheet we were
an equity financed economy and what I
mean by that is if you looked at the
amount of money saved every year and the
amount of money borrowed every year it
was essentially equal year in year out
the borrowing that people did in the
United States was from every from
somebody else's savings within the
United States so we were what I would
call an equity finance economy we were
not borrowing against our future in
order to consume more today and we
started doing exactly that in 1968
that's when the guns and butter programs
so to speak were where we're taking
effect and so a lot of people point to
1971 as the problem I actually point to
1968 that's the year in which we started
really out living our means and every
year since then except for 2009 the
United States has outlived our means and
so how are we able to sustain it for 50
years I think a lot of people are are
saying well gosh we don't have to care
about the debt this is a this something
you'll read in mainstream media we don't
have to care about the debt because we
owe it to ourselves or we can just print
money and therefore you know we can just
push pedal to the metal and keep
printing money and borrowing and to
respond to these crises with monetary
and fiscal policy respectively it used
to be one or
now it's both and now neither one of
them seems to be working very well the
quantity of stimulus that we're having
to throw at this most recent crisis is
staggering because the size of the
bubble is that much more staggering
because we've had so much debt issued
that's non-productive in in especially
the last decade but even especially the
last two years and so what I would say
to those folks is you got lucky the ones
who think that that debt doesn't matter
you got lucky because for 50 years we
were able to do this in the United
States because our parents and
grandparents and their parents and
grandparents bequeathed us with an
unbelievable balance sheet we net debt
on our balance sheet up until 1968 in
the United States we were we were we
were all the borrowing that that people
did in the United States was was out of
somebody's savings and so that net debt
was zero for decades and then we started
going to town in 1968 and you know
unfortunately
if you look at the balance sheet of the
United States right now it's kind of an
ugly situation we have 83 points three
trillion of non financial sector debt
outstanding again that's the that's
households businesses and governments
together I would also add the Fed's
balance sheet is is should be added to
that as well so we're really north of 87
trillion of debt and I looked it up last
night the net wealth of the United
States is 104 trillion as of year-end
2019 so we've got right and that's
that's not fleeting the debt is
contractual that's that's somebody's
debt you know real obligation that's
real whereas some of the assets backing
that hundred four trillion dollar number
are not real they're fleeting right we
just saw 20 trillion come off the stock
market so if we've got eighty eighty
seven trillion of debt and 104 trillion
of net wealth to satisfy that and we
just took twenty trillion of value off
financial assets last week you do the
math this is why people I think are not
on are not irrational to be to be
nervous about the situation and start
questioning whether the things they've
been taught are really right yes so you
bring up a great point about this idea
of kind of the net debt right I always
think of it as sure your local your
family household is if you save more
than you spend then you're usually in a
good spot you've got kind of a strong
balance sheet and you can continue
forever
if you start to get in a little bit of
debt well you can kind of catch back up
you can pay it off if you make a little
bit more money or approved it put
together a plan right we see that with
student loans for example etc that yeah
it's a big number for a lot of people
but they eventually pay it off over time
but if you keep increasing the debt and
you don't necessarily match that with
growth and GDP etc it's a little bit
harder to kind of catch up so it feels
like you're always kind of falling
farther and farther behind where do I
mean what is the the point at which
either the day can't be paid back
there's some other solution maybe
there's not a solution you need a
massive correction like how do you think
about where this all ends whether that
happened
you know in 2020 or in 2050 whenever it
actually happens don't worry about the
timing but like what is that end point
that this all kind of is yeah that I've
spent the last since 2008 reading about
this and thinking about this and
debating about it in my own head are we
gonna end in a deflationary crash are we
gonna end in a hyperinflationary melt up
and and the answer is we'll probably
have a little bit of both in sequence
yeah yes sir well but just explain what
both of those are for those that don't
know the deflationary and also the
hyperinflation explain those before you
kind of get into what what you think
you
okay Linda Lou
hold on one second guys let's see what
happened here
we might have lost her hold on see if we
can get this back get her back in here
Oh Caitlin says she's gonna join us
right back here in a second she just had
a power glitch I think so let's uh let's
just give her a second she should be
getting right back in see what happens
while we're waiting for Kaitlyn to get
back in though if you guys want when
we're done with recording this we're
gonna rip the audio and we're gonna put
up as a podcast and then also try to get
it on on Twitter as well
Kaitlyn is texting me right now and she
said the power just went out so stick
with us here for a second
and let's see what we can do here okay
try
as want once we finish obviously
subscribe to the YouTube channel
and go ahead and share this link
Caitlin's power just went out and she's
gonna try to tether to get back in here
so just bear with us and I think we'll
uh we ought to get her back in finish
talking a little bit about the repo
markets and then also she's going to
give us a good understanding of how
everything what the Federer is I think
Haley can you hey I'm back
I'm tethering I'm on yeah sorry about
that oh my god all good we got [ __ ] I
covered for you while you were gone I
told them that you were doing important
things like trying to get the internet
back on oh yeah sorry about that you
know what actually I'm that I can tell
my connections not very good because I'm
just untethering on an iPhone so well
the power is out I don't have I don't
have my good Wi-Fi so I don't have video
why don't I turn the video off hopefully
everybody yeah that'll that'll allow us
to have less interference is that okay
pump new it yeah that's that's perfectly
fine
so what let's um let's just jump right
back in about you were talking about a
lot of the balance sheet with the bank
can you hear me okay oops did I lose you
nope I'm so here can you hear me did I
lose you can you hear me
Kaitlyn Kaitlyn okay can you hear me
you cool I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
talk oh it looks like the power just
came back on so chaos here a little bit
I don't know what's going on anyway
I just forgot where we were maybe let's
change gears and talk about the real
commutes right here you can you uh can
you reap romp the question yeah I just
sent you if you can talk about the repo
markets
kaitlin just go ahead if you can hear us
and just go ahead and talk about the
repo market
let's see if we can get her back on to
the power alright I think she's gonna
try to reconnect not on tether but on
her on her actual computer here let's
just give her a second but if you guys
want I think that after this we're gonna
try to answer some questions as well on
on Twitter so if you run over there and
just tag Kaitlyn and on your questions
so we get done recording we will go
ahead and try to do our best to answer
as many of them as we can
she is resetting all of her internet and
connections so hopefully we can we can
get her on here shortly and she could
talk about the repo markets and then
kind of the government responds to a lot
of this all right are you back
Wow sorry about that and power went off
and all right about that and know your
life we're all hearing glitches in the
next couple weeks that haven't happened
before so sorry about that but now the
lights are not on behind me anyway
you're all good maybe let's just jump
into the repo markets you kind of
explain what the issues are there and
what you've seen and kind of why that's
important for people to continue paying
attention to yeah well as I mentioned
the repo market is is essentially how
the big banks fund themselves
when we had traditional banks it was
literally yours and my deposits at our
corner bank that that funded the banks
and then of course the monetary base
when the Fed either expanded or reduced
its balance sheet respectively would add
or reduce funding for the for the bank
so that's the way the traditional
banking system works increasingly in the
last especially the last 20 years the
repo market is how the big banks fund
themselves I make a big distinction
between the big banks on the corner
though thirds there they're really well
funded not a hundred percent but they're
much better funded than than they were
in 2008 the big banks are where the
problems are in my humble opinion
because they're so reliant on what's
called wholesale funding which is the
repo market and what that is is
basically they're just they're just
posting securities as collateral for
financing typically overnight but you've
noticed that the Fed has started to
actually expand to what's called turn
repo which is something over
and then you know longer than overnight
loans but there's an enormous amount of
leverage in the repo market there's a
mainstream economist whose work I have
tremendous respect for who's been doing
a lot of work on just how leveraged the
securities industry is and and and he
uses the year-end financial statement
filings which actually are are shall we
say window dressed because everybody at
quarterly financial period reporting or
year-end financial period reporting
brings their leverage down it's it's
really obvious in the market that this
is this happens so take these numbers
with a grain of salt but he estimated
how basically that what he called
collateral velocity which is how much
collateral there is that the big banks
can use to fund themselves and then
reuse and reuse and reuse and reuse that
code
piece of collateral is reused three
times at your end down from four times
before the financial crisis so we have
de leverage but since the financial
crisis but there's still a tremendous
amount of leverage and again these are
the year-end numbers for my experience
and I did do some work in the repo
market earlier in my career for my
experience that the the intra period
repo is probably two to three times that
size so what does that mean that means
then if we have a quickly think of runs
on the bank as being like in the movie
It's a Wonderful Life that's the
traditional banking system where
everybody goes and wants to withdraw
their deposits we can have runs on the
bank in the in the wholesale financial
system that the securities or shadow
banking system that's all different
terms for the same thing which is
basically the the it's it's it's secured
financing where where people are posting
security
as collateral for secured loans and
that's the way that those those firms
financed themselves and so when you get
a run on the shadow system the challenge
is that nobody's printing anymore
Treasury bonds out of thin air right if
they have to be issued the Fed can
always print more money out of thin air
but Treasury bonds have to be issued by
the US Treasury and of course we have
debt ceiling limits and things like that
so that's that's kind of a fly in the
ointment of that system it so it's much
more leveraged and it's actually much
more I'm than the traditional banking
system is and that's partly what you're
seeing here now we saw this past week
some very interesting announcements
Boeing and Wynn Resorts and a couple of
other you know big-name companies did
something called drawing on their
revolvers the revolving loans are issued
by these big banks to the big companies
and they provide backup liquidity and
nobody ever draws on these revolvers
they're not
drop but Boeing drew thirteen and a half
billion on its revolver this past week
that is a staggering number and the
banks don't keep that kind of liquidity
around so what that does is basically
kind of trigger a rung on this I'm a
shadow financing system because the
banks then have to go and find the
liquidity to do that which means they
have to post more collateral in order to
get get get more repo financing and it
just causes the the market to seize up
this isn't Boeing's fault that what I'm
laying out here is that the market was
inherently unstable
you know you would have understood why
giving the the green light to the big
banks to buy back their stock which is
reducing their equity was the exact
opposite last June of what what the
regulator should have been doing they
should have been actually making them
increase their equity and that's the but
that's the drum that a few a very small
number of
but it's definitely falling on deaf ears
yeah so I recently had Raul Paul come on
and one of the things that he really
highlighted was kind of this twofold
problem that is Part A the debt fueled
stock buybacks that are happening across
the market right so the whole idea is a
corporation is issuing debt they're then
getting that cash they're doing stock
buybacks they increase their earnings
per share because they're literally you
know changing the denominator there and
what the shareholders to some degree but
it's also really enriching the executive
teams who a lot of their compensation is
tied to a stock price and options etc
part of that is one if they can't issue
the debt anymore than they can't buy
back their stock and if they can't buy
back their stock then it's can be
propped up the way that it has been over
the last few years but that's all
centered on part two which is well who's
buying that corporate debt or that crap
and right now it's a lot of the pensions
across the u.s. it's been buying that
and so if all of a sudden they're left
holding credit that may or may not be
good do you actually have a two-part
problem which is one stock buybacks no
longer work and can't prop up prices but
then to now you have a bunch of pensions
that are holding stuff that ends up
being worth less than they bought and
they get themselves in trouble so how do
you think about the stock buybacks and
that pension problem oh did we just lose
her again all right let's wait a second
here Kaitlyn she had the power go out
earlier guys so just bear with us a
second she should be back in the in a
minute
she yep she just she just texted me and
said that the power just went out a
second time so uh and then it just came
back on so just give her a second and
she'll show come back but what I said
when she went last time is if you guys
have questions for Kaitlyn and I just go
ahead and tag both of us on Twitter and
then when we get done with alive
any of those as we can but that's why
you kind of asked questions about
anything that she's talking about and
let's see hey try cutting the video
everyone in the YouTube chat is asking
ok Katelyn is logging back in yeah it's
it's not so much the the video problem
with the power of where she is is
actually going out so she's losing
complete power so give her a second here
um and we'll be be back in business here
in a second but what one of the things
that I want people to kind of be aware
of is the fact that the stock buybacks
are obviously really positive for the
people who are holding the stock and for
executives who are getting paid either
based on stock performance or paid in
stock options but there's two part
problem one is you know 50-plus percent
of Americans can't afford the four
hundred dollar emergency
therefore they don't really hold any
assets other than cash so that's not
super helpful to them but then the
second piece of this is also where the
money to do the stock buybacks are
coming from a lot of times is they're
issuing debt to as being bought by
pension funds which can cause a big
problem as well so let's let's wait here
at another second or two for uh for
Kaitlyn to come back into the chat and
like I said if you guys want go have I'm
happy to answer them after the live
stream and then this week also I should
mention we are going to be writing a
whole bunch about what's going on the
more macro economy in different asset
markets etc so if you're interested go
to pump dotsub STATCOM and you can
subscribe to the newsletter we're going
to be cranking out a bunch of content
there it's really just trying to help
people understand one what's going on to
what they should be paying it
and then three kind of how we think the
solutions will uh what will kind of come
to fruition here so let's wait another
second or two and hopefully Kaitlyn can
get back in once once the power comes
back on
she is currently in Wyoming and I have
no clue what's going on with their power
but uh she has lost power twice now so
hopefully will be a will be good to go
in a second when she when she gets back
in so maybe if you want also Joe is
helping us to the live stream if there's
any good questions from this let me see
if I can log in real quick and and find
some questions from the YouTube channel
I can answer a couple of those were
waiting here liquidity yes a lot of
people are asking about liquidity I'll
speak for myself and Caitlin can come in
and if we get her back in she can she
can speak for herself but basically the
the big thing around liquidity I think
is in times of liquidity crisis no
matter what the asset is people are
gonna go oh we got killing back I think
it's is unbelievable I'm sorry this was
not happened before we got it looks like
it's a god it looks like it's a whole
neighborhood I don't know what's going
on normally pretty stable here there
you're good we left off I was asking you
about come the debt-fueled stock
buybacks and how a lot of people that
are buying net debt from corporations is
to pension funds and kind of pension
crisis maybe talk a little think through
that situation and what people should
pay attention to well I ran the pension
the business of corporate pension funds
purchasing annuities to settle their
pension obligations so transferring the
risk to the insurance industry which is
really where pension risk belongs
because they can manage it a lot better
than a corporation can and by the way
the companies that actually did settle
their pension obligations a lot of them
got done in 2012 to 2016 2017 period a
lot of smart companies did that tinners
they they funded their pensions and paid
off the obligations that the ones that
that that the one that I would highlight
one is bristol-myers Squibb go look at
the evolution of bristol-myers balance
sheet and he hats off to them they
understood that the risk of a big
decline in interest rates was was
potentially going to balloon
and so it was better for them to pay off
that obligation when they did and so a
lot of other companies did partial
transactions GM Motorola Verizon etc a
lot of others but it but anyway those
those finance officers of those
companies look smart but oh they did
issue debt because they had the ability
to cheaply as we've alluded to but
haven't really dug into yet interest
rates have been are held artificially
low and that has caused all kinds of
massive misallocation of capital you
were alluding to what you talked about
with roll on companies issuing debt at
artificially low rates to buy back their
stock at high stock prices boy history's
not going to view those decisions very
well at all in fact a lot of that debt
that got issued is literally capital
that was destroyed right because what
did it get invested in it got invested
in
docks at the peak of a stock market and
companies would have been better off in
retrospect not having done it at all and
instead just either paying out dividends
or holding on to their own cash and some
I put the fault for a lot of this
actually squarely in Congress's at
Congress's doorstep because they created
a situation that made it easy or that
that favored stock purchase stock
buybacks over dividends because
dividends taxed at higher interest
income tax rates and stock buybacks are
capital gains tax that's that capital
gains tax rates which have been lower so
this is Congress's fault that it
happened and again an August part and
parcel with the whole notion of just
basically encourage America to lever up
for the last 50 years we've been doing
this but the bigger picture aspect of
what happened here is that you know when
the debt is issue is invested in
something productive something that
earns a real return over the real cost
of that debt I'm not talking about the
market subsidized cost of that debt we
all acknowledge that that interest rates
were held too low and so so people
thought their cost of capital was a lot
lower than it really was
and now it's whip sighing and the cost
of capital is being revealed to be a lot
higher than it really was and projects
that they should not have in that they
did invest in they should not have
invested in and would not have invested
in had they known that the real cost of
capital was a lot higher than what the
market is telling them and that's the
big picture takeaway here is that the
BRIT the real problem of the debt bubble
is that it kept interest rates
artificially low and caused a ton of
misallocation of capital and as I noted
in the tweet storm yesterday that seven
and a half trillion of total debt that
got issued it got added to the United
States balance sheet collectively in the
last two years between the household
and businesses probably most of that
debt represents destroyed capital
there's probably not much of that debt
that where the investment is actually
going to pay off in terms of real
economic returns and so now here here we
are seeing the banks which is where you
always see the the default probability
problem arise now we're seeing the banks
having to to deal with the fact that
there are going to be mass defaults in
entire industries the biggest example of
which where you've seen just a real
collapse in stock prices in the last
week yeah and so I guess what that
really leads us to is this quiddity
crisis over the last week where people
literally just around the room and say
what do I own that's got a liquid market
attached to it how can I sell it
immediately and I want that liquidity
and we see all of these assets whether
it's gold Treasuries coin anything
correlations are spending Falls one
everything goes down because liquidity
crisis may be kind of talk through how
that works and then we can get into how
governments have to respond or the Fed
has to respond to those types of see
yeah so the leverage players always the
lenders always want collateral in the
financial markets and when they're
making loans I guess been technically
not always but the vast vast majority of
leverage and the third buy financial
assets and so what happens in these
situations is that when you have an
investor who has to deal Everage they're
getting a margin call they have to post
more collateral because the value of the
assets securing their loan just went
down just getting a giant margin call
and they're going to sell whatever is
easy to sell now I talked about how
there were dislocations in the in the US
Treasury bond market of all markets last
week
I'm liquid and so people were selling
whatever haven't whatever was liquid and
and and whatever hadn't been nailed down
yet and when you see Gold's go down I
learned this from watching the 2008
financial crisis Gold also plunged in
2008 it a lot of people would have said
oh that's not a safe-haven asset because
it plunged well well oftentimes the
safe-haven assets are the first ones
that are actually sold precisely because
they aren't somewhat tied up in some of
these crazy you know leveraged financial
structures always their leverage has
definitely got an impact on them alright
we can talk about the gold ETFs or talk
about all the leverage in the Bitcoin
market but at the at the bottom those
assets are nobodies IOU
they are assets that if you own the real
thing if you own the physical gold or
you own your your private keys for your
crypto assets they're they're yours you
have outright title to those assets
they're nobodies IOU use and so
oftentimes because of that those assets
are the first ones that get sold and we
certainly saw that in 2008 we certainly
saw that last week we saw a huge
correction in Bitcoin a much lower
correction in gold but golden exactly
act like a supposed safe haven either
now all that said I don't think that one
week matters for either one of those
assets and in fact actually we just
flushed out a lot of the leverage I
think in the in the crypto market I
wouldn't be shocked if some of the
crypto financial institutions didn't
survive last week and we just don't know
it yet and by the way good riddance
the the the the amount of speculative
leverage that was taking place on an
asset that shouldn't be leveraged has
been staggering and the faster we can
clear out that cruft from the market the
better off the market is I I think those
safe haven assets are true safe havens
but that doesn't mean they're gonna be
safe havens every day and they were they
were the easiest things sell laughy when
you see gold go down it means that we're
really having serious liquidations yeah
and I think what you alluded to in 2008
I wrote this piece is past week that
I don't know in 2008 kind of the mid
6-month liquidity crisis period kind of
over the summer goal actually went down
30% during that time period but if he
then zoom out to the entire crisis kind
of ended 2006 to end of 2011 it was up
3x so in there there is that liquidity
crisis you draw it out you know pretty
substantially for the quote-unquote safe
haven asset if you look at Treasuries
for example their season you know the
markets are seizing up again does that
that doesn't mean that it's not a safe
haven type asset or not something that
people want to to get I think Bitcoin
same thing right you see this massive
volatility the other thing that people
have to understand is the market cap of
an asset like Bitcoin it plays into this
it's a smaller market cap it's gonna be
much more volatile but the one data
point I thought was a hunter Horsley
from wise I was tweeting this I thought
was really interesting if you look at
the historical volatility of Bitcoin and
let's say the SNP the SNP going down
nine and a half percent on a relative
basis is the equivalent of Bitcoin going
down 51 percent and so what you saw last
week was the sed went down 9 and then
went down 50 percent so on a relative
volatility basis they actually were just
as volatile as you know each one of them
which I thought was super interesting
now that leads us to ok we get the
liquidity crisis every asset trends
towards 1 on the correlation they all go
down obviously we're going to see
monetary stimulus step in we saw some of
that last week the markets pricing in a
hundred percent likelihood of a rate cut
coming up here I think it's this week
talk to us about how does the government
and the Fed respond to all of this and
then we can talk about kind of the
impact at all
these safe-haven assets are kind of
sound money properties yeah well let me
before we talk to how the government's
going to respond you what you said
prompted a really important thought
again this is not advice but it's just a
lens through which everybody should
think about their own financial
situation I would really encourage
everyone to start thinking not in
nominal terms but in real terms what do
I mean by that if the ass if we're in a
deflationary environment and your assets
are going down by less than the index is
going down your cost of living then you
come out ahead
same thing if we're in an inflationary
environment and your your personal
inflation rate is less than the
inflation rate of the economy or your
that's our going up by more than that
you come out ahead so we've been in the
u.s. really lulled into complacency
because we don't have to think about
foreign exchange rate risk since oils
priced in dollar commodities are priced
in dollars right the rest of the world
has to think about exchange rate risk
all the time it's their norm and so this
whole notion of just because the
numerator is going up the nominal price
is changing that means that my personal
situation follows that uh-uh
we need to start realizing that and I've
been thinking about that for years that
the stock market going up just meant the
dollars value was actually going down
you need to start thinking about that
and and so you know literally the the
best stock market in the last few years
has been Venezuela
well that's B's because the denominator
was going down just think about the
algebra right if all you're paying
attention to is the numerator you're
missing the point you've got to pay
attention to the denominator and whether
the denominator is is changing value or
not so now let me get to answering
question about what what policymakers
are going to do what they should do is
what policymakers did in 1920 which is
nothing there was a depression in 1920
and most of you are probably surprised
to hear me talk about it because most of
you if you haven't read economic history
didn't know it happened because it
didn't get all the attention why because
it was really short but it turns out it
was as nasty as the depression in the
Great Depression from 1929 to 36 and and
so the nineteen the depression of 1920
was literally one year and it was as
extreme we saw unemployment go to 12%
we saw GDP go down almost 20% and you
know what President Harding did he
overruled her Herbert Hoover who was his
Treasury secretary who wanted to
intervene and try to prop up industries
and try to keep companies in business
and you know what he did he overruled
Hoover and said let's pay down the US
debt we've just been coming off World
War one and by the way that Spanish flu
of 1918 is an interesting parallel right
that we had a
global pandemic the war was over and and
the US president was confronted with a
depression where unemployment spiked
from 4 percent to 12 percent in a very
very short period of time GDP contracted
almost 20 percent and you know what he
did he paid down one third of the US
government's debt and the Fed did
nothing and the reason why none of us
have ever heard of the depression of
1920 is precisely because it was only
one year and what gets all the attention
was the terrible experience of of the
greater depression in 1929
well what happened then the government
tried to prop up industries with fiscal
policy and and and the Fed got actively
involved and it
it just extended the duration of the
pain the balance sheet reconstruction
wasn't allowed to happen fast and so
this is the one that we all think about
it and and we've read about it in
history books but the one we really
ought to be reading about is the Great
Depression of 1922 start there
so back now I'm pumped again to your
question what are people what are what
our governments going to do they're
gonna make the same mistake they made in
1830 which is which is pedal to the
metal on the debt and actually make the
balance sheet in even worse condition
than that than it is today and prolong
the pain as opposed to just backing off
if I were a policy maker I would do
nothing I would let the chips fall where
they may
I would tell the banks get out there and
raise equity capital but you're on your
own I'm not gonna force you to do it but
you're on your own boy the boy they they
would rush to the market to raise equity
capital like that if they knew they were
really truly on their own and would go
up if they did very counterintuitive
typically when you raise raise equity
capital you're diluting the existing
shareholders except when the reason for
the stocks
which actually make the problem worse
and prolong the pain and so when they do
this
I guess there's two repercussions to
that the first is do you think that it
will actually work and then two is what
will that do or what will the response
with gold Bitcoin other kind of safe
haven or sound money property type
assets what is the response to those
assets near
well actually they probably go down if
the if the policymakers did what they
should do but because they probably
won't because politicians always want to
seem like they're in control and always
want to promise left pain they're there
they're gonna try to prop up industries
I I turned on CDC for the first time in
quite a while last week just because
they've got really good you know minute
to minute coverage of what's going on
with market circuit breakers and things
like that and I was listening to Jim
Cramer say we got to figure out which
industries were going to save that is
exactly the opposite thinking that we
should be having right now but
unfortunately you know he's indicative
of how the powers that be think and
again it's this is I'm not making a
political point we've had a string of
bad presidents and bad decision economic
decision-makers for 50 years in the
United States most of our natural lives
and and so he's just reflecting that way
of thinking of the world which is we got
to figure out which industries to save
no we shouldn't we should be letting
markets allocate capital to the to those
that will produce new capital from it as
opposed to those guess all worse off and
by saving industries that need to be
saved were we're just throwing good
money after bad yeah I think this is a
really point because there there's two
components and I'm generally aligned
with you on this which is one the whole
idea of what a lot of people now are
calling kind of corporate socialism
right I wrote about you know Kramer's on
television literally begging the Fed to
step in begging for this stuff and you
know I said it's hilarious it would be
hilarious if it wasn't so sad to see the
critical catalyst begging for the
bailouts right and what ends up
happening is nobody want to have the
hard conversation right at David Sachs
actually just wrote about this from
Kraft Ventures he wrote about happy talk
versus hard talk and happy talk is
basically everyone's saying you know hey
it's gonna be okay gonna be okay it's
going great but whatever at a company
and then only at the last second all of
a sudden the founder moves to hard talk
with the board and says hey we're
running out of money we got to make hard
decisions and we need to do it fast but
the whole idea is that
end up being the most resilient they
have the hard talk from day one they're
always super honest super job they're
constantly questions and I think that's
what needs to happen in the financial
system now your point is if there are
things that are going to fail it's
probably because they are bad strategy I
don't have sound down to begin with yes
there's always that good the whole idea
is if you take a non-emotional
non-political view that would make sense
let the bad companies fail let the bad
industries fail let all of this occur
now the the kind of social aspect of
this I think is where people get really
uncomfortable right because logically
that makes sense if it's a bad company
if its profitable if the economics don't
make sense they're over leveraged
whatever let that all fail people get
really hurt and when that happens though
right and I think that where the
trade-off comes in is people are gonna
lose their jobs their short-term pain
but what it does is it builds a
healthier system over a long period of
time kind of your point about that 19:20
depression that there is the short-term
pain but that's the cleaning out of the
the market of the bad things instead
what ends up happening is we try to
prevent short-term pain but we actually
end up building a bigger and bigger
bubble and so 2008 was painful ah well
you see what happens next if they can't
come over the top with this monetary
stimulus into your point going from a
four trillion dollar balance sheet to 10
trillion people think that's a crazy
idea
I don't think Rosie's like they just
announced 1.5 trillion or Nothing so she
got a string yeah no exactly well that
is corporate welfare right there but but
to your point back in 1920 the the the
unemployment rate was I think 2 percent
and then it jumped to 12 and within one
year it was back down to 6 and then
within another year it was back down to
2 so it was a painful couple years but I
think everyone steeled themselves we're
gonna have a painful couple years at
least of painful six months anyway just
simply because of the virus leaving all
the economics aside the virus is
definitely gonna cause a lot of
disruption we know that and a lot of
pain restaurants are gonna close you
know a lot of people who are
in the service industry are gonna are
really going to have a lot of pain this
is where you have to have your local
communities and families take care of
each other its local charities it's
families it's it's your it's your own
personal circle you know if you've got
an elderly neighbor check in on them
they might not want to go right now when
when you know tensions are high in the
grocery stores they might need and
really appreciate you helping them to
you know make sure their refrigerators
full so it I think this is where local
help is really going to matter and
because frankly I'm fortunately I just
don't think people gonna be able to rely
on the government for help and it's not
gonna be awful at some point yeah it's
gonna be painful but the the people to
your point I think there's a
psychological aspect of all this those
of us who've unfortunately understood
all this and been waiting for the credit
bubble to finally be pricked and a
paradigm shift to come we're we're over
the shock of it I think the vast
majority of Americans are in that shock
phase right now of oh my god something's
really wrong now what do I do
there's a good story that I can relay
from someone who worked in the airline
industry who investigated airline
crashes and he told me once that you
know when he gets to the crash site in a
Neal's down says
throws up and then gets to gets to work
you know pulls out his folding table and
chair and sits down and starts working
and and I think that's what people need
to need to do that's sort of the the the
shock phase which is where a lot of
folks are those of us who have read the
history and expected this to come maybe
are not as shocked maybe we did start
hunkering down a little bit bit sooner I
did start telling my family I'm to the
grocery store I really started pounding
on that a few weeks ago and and and you
know we can we can think more clearly
there are going to be huge opportunities
the world is not going to end this is
just a restructuring and whether whether
the Fed is able to reinflates a system
or whether we really are in a paradigm
shift either in either case whenever
that paradigm shift comes because I'm
pretty confident that it is going to
come during my lifetime
yeah I know that I can start thinking
about what the world that emerges on the
other side is gonna look like and don't
shoot the messenger right none of the
people it involved today none of the
policymakers created this situation we
really have to go back to the late 60s
and early 70s that was the seeds of the
the problems that we're seeing today
every single politician every single
president every single banker every
single monetary policy maker is is in
part responsible for perpetuating the
system but none of them created it
because the people who created it are
long dead but but all that said you know
we if we can actually just be resilient
somebody actually have notice here
somebody actually gave a great tweet
response when I check my Twitter this
morning opportunity favors the prepared
mind to the person who said that thank
you that is such a positive way of
thinking about the situation that that
we're here facing now if you prepare
yourselves for it that's how you spot
opportunities there's gonna be so many
opportunities for entrepreneurs to make
money in the new economy and I am
actually really optimistic that once we
get through this short term horrible
situation which is going to be awful and
it's gonna affect everybody I think
everybody family is gonna be affected by
this virus it is that contagious but
more importantly everybody's livelihood
is going to be impacted by by what's
gonna happen in the financial system
once we get through the other side of
that man there's this the hard work is
again going to truly be rewarded the
system is going to be a lot more fair
it's going to be a lot more stable we're
going to have a lot better visibility
into it the elites who have let us down
are not going to be in power in the same
to the same extent that they are today
this is actually a better world we've
just got to get from here to there and
and and take care of our families and
our neighbors in the meeting yeah and
and before we close I want to kind of
just touch on the idea that a lot of
people who are begging for the monetary
stimulus these are people who are
they are rich they own real assets they
are part of the Aliyah and the reason
that they want the monetary stimulus is
because the downside of the quantitative
easing the Fed expansion of their
balance sheet et cetera is it devalues
the currency hold the currency you don't
care about that but the kind of
counter-argument those who say oh the
people are going to be hurt when their
company goes out of business etc there
are many many more people that end up
getting hurt from a wealth inequality
standpoint when we then go and just
print trillions of dollars and I don't
think that people really understand that
right it's more of a hey on the ground
somebody lost their job I can measure
that I can't really see the systemic
damage that
you know if you go back and you look at
the ultimate quality from 2008 to today
it's just an ever-expanding gap and and
I think that that's part of this is that
people are saying oh here comes all this
monetary stimulus all I hear is the
50-plus percent of Americans that can't
make a $400 emergency payment or about a
get even more of their wealth stolen
there's got to be an acceleration what
of the theft of their wealth by that
currency that they all hold and what it
does is it's going to shift even more
wealth and eventually power into the
hands of the elite we should be yelling
and screaming from the rooftop if you do
this you're actually hurting majority of
the people rather than helping them I
just don't think people see that yet
oh I think the vast majority of people
do that's the silent majority that's out
there the so-called Forgotten man of
Amity slays her book by the way by that
name The Forgotten man is a wonderful
historic historical work another one is
when money dies by Adam Ferguson these
are historians so you're not going to
get the you know that the political lens
as much as you would by reading an
economists view a lot of folks are
looking for books to read I would
encourage you to read both of those that
said if you're anxious don't read those
right now because you know those are
stories about about very difficult times
if you want to be a prepared mind
they're probably good stories to read
but if you're anxious they'll just make
even more anxious because they're you
know it shows you the range of the
possible outcome we may be facing here
but that said you know I've actually had
this conversation of was it better to
have anticipated this going back to 2008
or in someone with my friends cases
going back even longer and lived with
that weight on your shoulders over that
whole period of time knowing that this
was potentially coming or was it better
to actually not to to believe that we
really were as wealthy as we thought we
were and and and to you know live in
blissful ignorance of how unstable the
situation was I can see both sides of it
but personally I'm glad I'm in that camp
of people who understood it because it
helped me prepare my family help me
prepare mentally for what's happening
helps me think more clearly through
through the situation and and I was
pretty negative about the world going
into it coming off the financial crisis
for those few years as I was reading all
those books it did definitely bring me
down again that's my warning to you
don't read them if it's going to bring
you down but then then then came along
Bitcoin in 2012 and I spotted the impact
of that that's not a speculative asset
back when we were talking about earlier
in the interview about the price of
Bitcoin I really don't care about the
price of Bitcoin I care about one thing
and one thing only is the network
working is it stable and you know what
that network stability this week was
stunning in the face of all this price
volatility and Hugh
increasing volume every 10 minutes the
Bitcoin blockchain added a new block and
it's not price stable it never has been
but it has its systemically stable and
that's not to say that it's not going to
continue to be I am not giving anybody
advice here I'm just saying that this is
one of the alternatives one of the one
of the ways you can empower yourself is
to educate yourself we're all gonna be
stuck in our homes for the next at least
couple weeks read read books read the
history if you're curious about the
history and again you're you can steel
yourself for the anxiety if you are
anxious and and and and would rather
talk a turn to instead of understanding
the past what might come in the future
teach yourself how to control your own
private keys if there's one thing you
take away from this conversation its I
hope and understanding that some assets
are IOUs and others are not and I have a
feeling that that's going to turn out to
be a pretty important distinction all
financial assets stocks bonds you know
your ETFs your bank deposits all
financial assets are IOUs of leveraged
financial institutions who have been
given corporate welfare in spades and
levered themselves up and made
themselves not very sustainable the big
banks especially but on the flip side
there are all kinds of assets that you
can own where you can control it
yourself and you own it outright land
your house your car your your you know
here orange groves if you invest in that
you know agricultural property jewelry
precious metals and cryptocurrencies and
and I would just encourage you to start
reading about all those because think
about your wealth differently a lot of
people there's an ad on TV where there's
an older couple that's it talks about oh
we hand it off to our financial advisor
he knows
Kizer lives in that traditional
financial system and isn't really
thinking about wealth preservation the
way that I've been thinking about it
you know since 2008 it's definitely not
too late and there's no substitute for
educating yourself that's the most
empowering thing that that I can advise
folks to do take these next couple weeks
when you're with your families hug them
close and and take care of them take
care of your neighbors and then spend
the time educating yourselves about the
here opportunity it comes to those who
are prepared it's a great thought I
couldn't agree with you more and it's
actually I don't think I've ever said
this publicly but one of the ways that I
think about Bitcoin in allocating it
personally and again not financial
advice just how I personally think about
it is what percentage of my portfolio
and wealth do I want protected from the
quantitative easing and the monetary
stimulus etc and I think that over time
as people educate themselves like you
said I think that becomes much more
obvious to them but but again your your
point this week so you said a couple
different points of the Bitcoin network
is still operational still strong it's
still kind of doing exactly what it's
supposed to do if you compare that to
the legacy world right I think well I
saw you say somewhere that the legacy
world foundation is unstable and
everyone is focused on getting price
stability so the underlying fundamentals
almost don't matter as long as they have
price stability
if you flip that in Bitcoin everyone is
focused on the foundation being stable
and they don't care as much about the
price I ability voting things one of
them so well is optimizing for the the
Bitcoin right is obviously optimizing
for the long term and I think that's a
kind of perspective when you compare
those two things so you know we'll kind
of see how that plays out but listen I
appreciate you taking so much time to
this especially thinking through it with
with the two of power outages
in the next few weeks yeah I'm mostly
using my Twitter account these days so
at Kaitlyn long underscore CAI tli NL
Ong underscore I also do have a blog
Kaitlyn - long calm and post on LinkedIn
and stay tuned we haven't talked about
the bank that that I'm starting it is a
the Wyoming has a has an interesting
place in history because we where the
place that fought a mini civil war over
clarity of property rights it's the
Johnson County cattle war in the late
1890s over whether people over whether
landowners were allowed to fence out
trespassers in the form of of
we're driving their cattle up from from
the South could they go over private
property and we came down as a state
definitively after that experience on
the side of private property and it has
there's no accident that the banking
laws in Wyoming allow for a
special-purpose depository institution
that is 100 percent reserved in other
words not leveraged on the cash side but
also in Wyoming rehypothecation of app
of assets is and and literally people
have gone to jail this has been
litigated up to the Supreme Court in
Wyoming and upheld that if you own an
asset and you pledged it as collateral
for a loan and then you take that same
asset and then you reap legit as
collateral for a different loan that's a
felony is fraud and boy that exact
experience happens every single day in
the financial industry and in the state
of Wyoming it's it's a felony so where
I'm going is there are places in this
country that have it right and Wyoming
is one
and so I'm working on that and stay
tuned we will have a big announcement
coming out about about Avanti Bank this
week we won't have it open until early
2021 we're not technically a bank until
we get a charter and we're aiming for
early 2021 but I can't see it
an even bigger need than I see today for
a bank like that to come in and help the
digital asset industry so we're working
hard up you have one of your biggest
fans here I think what you're doing is
is incredible and you know for those
that don't know how hard you've been
working to kind of all this possible
from everyone else just thank you
because I think you're right that no
people are going to or important that
work is is coming up here so we'll have
to do this again as things kind of
transpire but I thank so much for taking
the two hours of your day to come to us
Caleb thanks everyone stay safe out
there thanks Bob